i hope that we're able to have this next
conversation
as adults and please watch the entire
video listen to the entire story before
commenting i'm begging you
i've actually i hate to admit this but
i've delayed talking about this for a
few days because i know that
even bringing it up triggers some people
off a cliff into a rationality but at
this point i would be doing a disservice
if i didn't talk about this so i'm going
to break it down as simply as i can
russia is once again meddling in the
election
in order to help donald trump now
disclaimer
listen listen very very carefully here
this does not mean donald trump is
actively participating or coordinating
anything with vladimir putin this does
not mean
that russia is coordinating with trump
what this means is that russia is doing
what they do all over the world
and what they've done for a very long
time and what the united states does
all over the world this is a really
important message here
i'm not alleging and i'm not alleging
anything it's the intelligence community
it is not being alleged that russia is
doing
anything special right now russia has a
long history dating back decades really
like a hundred years of using a series
of tactics depending on the situation to
exert
influence on foreign elections now for
everybody let's go through some of the
responses people are going to send me
what about china and iran i'll talk
about china and iran in two minutes so
let's wait
uh what about the fact that the u.s also
meddles in elections you're right
but i'm not in the of course the u.s
medals in elections
that's not what this story is about this
is about our election
being meddled in if you are against
trump and you want the will of the
people to be heard
and for it to be the will of the people
that determines the next president
right now we are talking about russian
meddling to help trump
in the next three months that's the
topic of this story it doesn't mean
some other thing isn't a valid story
americans meddling in nicaragua decades
ago
is true interesting and important
historically
it's just not what this story is about
so don't distract with that
so what do we know russia is pushing
their standard disinformation campaigns
targeting joe biden they're spreading
disinformation to hurt joe biden
the american intelligence community has
been briefing elected
elected officials about this now for
some time russia is working to help
donald trump by attacking biden and
meanwhile
yeah china and iran are working to hurt
trump
this is not just russia but you can't
deny the russia peace
that's the important thing russia
prefers trump china
and iran prefer joe biden based on
everything we know right now
doesn't make anybody better or worse
it's simply what is taking place right
now
the russian interference is not merely
about trump per se
and it's not even about trump
specifically it's about russia's bigger
plan to destabilize
western democracy anybody who thinks
russia's preferences
are specifically about trump as a person
you're you're mostly missing the big
picture russia plays a big picture game
the game is so discord in western
democracies
to make people within those countries
and around the world think
wow you know democracy doesn't seem to
be working so well
in these countries the more that western
democracies lose credibility
the better russia looks in comparison
that's the idea
making it a reality is another story now
in terms of their reactions to this
nationally
democrats and republicans are just not
the same on many issues
if you've been watching this program
listening to the podcast you know that i
point out
here's an issue on which there is very
little daylight between democrats and
republicans and when that's the case we
talk about it
on this issue since 2016
democrats have sought time after time
to stop and prevent this type of
meddling
republicans have gotten in the way
of trying to stop this type of meddling
mitch mcconnell
has gotten in the way of dealing with
this donald trump
has done nothing about it so please
understand there's not
anything conspiratorial here powerful
countries try to influence elections
around the world
assuming you agree that's true there's
no particular reason to doubt
russia having a preference and that
preference being donald trump because
it's coherent with their geopolitical
strategy dating back for decades
the us does it you're right china does
it yes iran does it
absolutely and so does russia there's no
reason
that we should be particularly skeptical
of that why would we deny it it doesn't
make any sense
the claim once again just as a reminder
is
not that trump and putin are working
together right now
the claim is from the intelligence
committee that the u.s election is just
another one
and russia is interested in the outcome
china's interested in the outcome
iran is interested in the outcome they
have different preferences
russia's preference is for trump to win
and russia's
tactics are likely more sophisticated
than those employed by
china and iran because russia has been
doing this for a very long time
don't be defensive in the sense that
accepting that
doesn't mean you have to accept anything
else you don't have to accept
anything that goes into speculation but
there are people that get
very defensive when this is brought up
and they start talking about red scares
and all sorts of wacky stuff
it just it's very straightforward
there's nothing unique here
let's identify it for what it is i'm
really excited that one of our sponsors
today is
helix sleep i sleep on a helix mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but
helix has a sleep quiz on their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video